(slow dramatic music)
- You can be everything.
Like be the greatest actor, actress,
singer, be an accountant,
be everything you can be.
You got one fucking life.
Don't let people put you in a fucking box.
Everybody's trying to put
people in a fucking box.
If you're fucking talented
enough, do everything.
If you're fucking Bo Jackson
and Deion Sanders, play both.
For example, I'm a good operator
and I'm a good personality, so I do both.
Some people are good personalities,
but can't run a business.
Some can run a business.
Some people can cook and sing,
some people can't.
Like, do you.
Like if you can do comedy
and fucking music, then go.
If you're good enough,
you'll always get it.
The Rock was a wrestler, now
he's a fucking movie star.
Will Smith was a fucking rapper,
then he was a fucking movie star.
Marky Mark was a fucking rapper,
then he was a movie star.
Life if you're; Ashton
Kutcher was an actor,
now he's a fucking baller businessman.
If you're good enough,
nobody's gonna stop you.
Listen, if you're talented enough,
if you're fucking Jamie Foxx, go.
People said I was fucking the wine guy,
I couldn't do business, cool.
Then I was an investor, I
couldn't do advertising.
Like, fuck your boxes.
You're not putting me in a fucking box.
All of you, all my 4,000 views
think you know what I'm about right now.
You don't know.
I might fucking start, I'm gonna be,
I might win a fucking Tony.
Cause honestly I can go on Broadway
and fucking destroy it,
I can feel it in my soul.
Not letting you fucking put me in a box.
Not everybody wants to be put in a box,
put people in a box.
I might start a fucking hotdog company
and fucking destroy the world
and fucking kill Nathan's
and be the greatest.
Or I might just flip the
fucking script in three years
and just go fucking disappear
and fuck buying the Jets
and fuck making videos and
fuck being a businessman
and fucking just teach
kids in fucking Pakistan.
I don't fucking know,
but I know one thing.
I'm definitely not gonna listen to you.
Put me in a fucking box.
Trying to put people in
a box which stops people
from doing what they actually want.
It's fucking 2019.
Go do your fucking thing.
Fuck.
I gonna do everything
I fucking want to do.
I got 60 more years of
fucking destroying it.
That's what I plan to do.
And regardless of what
the article's written
or what you guys are saying behind my back
or to my face or my DMs or the comments,
I'm fucking not letting anybody
put me in a box, nobody.
Not my family, not the world.
I'm gonna do me.
Peace and quite in my own fucking head.
That's all I want.
Don't you want happiness?
Don't you fucking wanna be happy?
Fuck.
Don't let anybody put
you in a fucking box.
Live.
Fuck boxes.
(slow dramatic music)